Hey, hi, Hussein. How are you? Thanks
for joining.
Hi, Ajit. I'm doing good. Thank you so
much. How are you doing?
I'm I'm good as well. Thank you for
asking. So, let's do one thing. Let's
quickly introduce
uh ourselves and then maybe we can deep
dive into the interview.
Sure.
Yeah, so would you like to introduce
yourself first? Sure, sure. I'll go
ahead. So, first of all, of course, as I
said, thank you so much for having this
call.
Uh I'm Hussein Lokhandwala having more
than 4.5 years of experience as a DevOps
engineer and I am certified in AWS,
Kubernetes, uh Terraform, and Azure.
I started my journey in 2021 as a junior
DevOps engineer. Worked there for 1.5
years and then I switched to my current
company where I'm working as a senior
DevOps engineer. So, mostly my
day-to-day uh activities look like we
support a US client where we work in
Agile methodology. We have junior
developers, uh junior DevOps and senior
DevOps in our team. So, mostly my
responsibility is to take care of the
tickets which are assigned to us. Uh
setting up the priority and uh
completing those tickets and also
assigning tickets to the junior DevOps.
And uh also I have to create few proof
of concepts for the clients and uh move
ahead if the those things goes well.
So, and I'm passionate about uh solving
complex problems and architecting new
things. Yeah, so this was about me.
Okay, thanks. Thanks, Hussein, for the
brief introduction. So, I will also
quickly introduce myself. So, I'm Ajit.
Uh I lead the technology team at one of
the service-based companies in India.
So, I have about total 14 years of
experience in the IT industry across
multiple domains and geographies. So,
for the initial uh 6 to 7 years of my
career, I was more into full-stack
development. Uh later on uh for next uh
like 4 to 5 years, I was into uh cloud
uh platform engineering solutioning and
few cloud leadership-related roles. Uh
last 1 and 1/2 years, I've taken a uh
leadership role at uh this particular
company where I'm heading the entire
technology unit. So, yeah. So, uh let's
let's get right into the content uh
about the interview. So, uh Hussein,
tell me one thing. How would you
architect a fully uh available and
fault-tolerant application on AWS?
Okay. So, first of all, I would assume a
couple of things like the application is
a data analytics and there are a lot of
services required. So, we would go with
EKS there. And we'll start from the
basics first uh talking about the
networking part. Uh we will create
private subnets, public subnets. And I
will make sure that the compute and
database is in the private subnet. And
the application load balancer and those
stuffs are in the public subnet and
accordingly we'll set up the NACL and
security groups.
Talking about
part, we would use S3. S3 also we'll
enable cross-region application so that
in another region we also are
replicating data.
Uh then for databases, if you are using
RDS, then we'll make sure to enable
read replicas in cross-region as well
for disaster recovery processes. And if
the application allows, we would go with
DynamoDB because it supports global
tables.
Then coming on to compute, as I said
that we would use uh EKS. It also
supports cross-region node deployments.
And uh we will have a cluster in primary
region and also we will have a secondary
region EKS deployment there as well.
And
I because it provides
more in terms of security. Like RBAC
rules are there, then uh network
policies are there. And also deployment
is way easier in Argo uh
in Kubernetes using Argo CD
thing. And also we can
uh have rollbacks also easy in uh EKS.
So, considering those scenarios, I chose
uh EKS rather than going to ECS or uh
EC2.
Okay. Okay, and why do you think that
ECS won't be a good choice in that
particular scenario? Because I have seen
a lot of enterprise-grade companies use
ECS for their highly available and
fault-tolerant applications.
So,
what do you think? Uh you mentioned
about security. You mentioned about uh
Argo CD, right? You mentioned about
other things. So,
don't you think that ECS also provides
that kind of stuff which EKS does?
ECS also provides, but uh let's say in
terms of security, then only it will be
limited to AWS like you can have your
access in the rules of task definition
and mention that only. But on EKS, you
can get a lot of customizations
available. Again, it depends on the
application's need. Uh if the
application is okay to work on ECS, then
we can select that as well. But if you
need more complex uh more complex
architecture is there and more security
if you want, then I would prefer to go
with EKS.
Okay.
Uh can you tell me a scenario where ECS
will be better suited as compared to
EKS?
Sure. So, if you have a simple
deployment, you don't have a lot of
services and everything you think that
can be manageable inside AWS only and
the access management can be done using
the policies uh mentioned in the IM
roles. So, in those kind of scenario, we
can definitely go with ECS because there
also you just have to mention the task
definition and all the services that you
want. It It is definitely a reliable
choice. And the routes also you can
mention it in the application load
balancer. So, if you feel that
everything can be managed using those
specific services and you don't need a
complex services like ingress and uh STO
like those kind of services, then
definitely you can move ahead with ECS.
Okay. Uh and what do you think which one
is cheaper
uh as compared to each other?
Uh ECS is cheaper.
You see, why do you think ECS is
cheaper? Because it only uh costs around
the services that you use. In terms of
EKS, it will charge you for the EKS
cluster by default and no nodes are
running. And as soon as you spin up the
nodes, as soon as you
uh use a lot of services of EKS, so it
will be way more costlier.
Okay. So, you mean to say EKS uh
controller manager or maybe the actual
cluster is also uh billable and in in
case of ECS, only the underlying
infrastructure is billable.
Correct, yeah.
Okay, anything apart from that?
Hm.
Anything apart from that uh
I'm not able to think think of anything
as of now.
Okay, no worries. No worries. Okay, so
you also mentioned about public subnets
and private subnets, right? So, uh when
you create a subnet, there is no option
to maybe create a private subnet or a
public subnet, right? It is some
configuration that needs to be done to
make that particular uh subnet as public
or private. So, I wanted to understand
what is that configuration. How would
you make your uh subnet a public or a
private one?
Okay. So,
for making a subnet public or private,
the answer lies in the route tables
which is assigned uh which is which is
assigned to that particular subnet. So,
if you mentioned in the route table of a
subnet that uh the routes coming to that
subnet should go through internet
gateway, then it becomes a public
subnet. So, any route in that uh subnet
will go through internet. And if you
mention that there is also a capability
of NAT gateway that can be assigned that
can be attached to public subnet. And
you can mention a route in a subnet that
your any request should go to NAT
gateway. That will be a private subnet.
Okay. And uh internet gateway is
attached to a subnet or it is attached
to a VPC?
It is attached to a VPC.
Are you sure about that?
Yes. And
uh NAT gateway you said that it is
public subnet, right? Okay, okay. And
where are the rules? Uh
suppose I have a private subnet and my
private subnet needs access to the
internet, right? So, where would be my
outgoing rules in the public subnet or
the private subnet route table?
In the private subnet route table you'll
mention it that any request coming to
the private subnet should go through NAT
gateway.
All right. Okay. Okay, fine.
Have you worked with
hybrid networking in AWS?
Yes.
Okay, so
like if I have to connect my on-premises
network with AWS.
Can you list down all the choices you
have
to connect both the networks like your
on-prem as well as your AWS?
Correct. Sure. So, first option is
direct connect where you will if you
have tons and tons of workload that you
have to migrate or data transfer from
AWS cloud to on-premise or direct
connect is one of the option. Second
option is site-to-site VPN connection
where you can create a customer gateway
and AWS gateway and that also you can
connect your on-premise and cloud. And
one of third option that I could think
of is transit gateway. That is also
something that you can configure
to have your data transfer from AWS to
your on-premise.
So, if you have if you don't have a lot
of workload then transit gateway and
site-to-site VPN connection is a choice
because it is cheaper than direct
connect.
Okay. Any other networking options that
you can think of apart from these?
I think AWS hub services also there. I
am not able to remember that complete
name but that's one service is also
there.
Okay. Okay, fine.
Um
There is also VPC peering, right
in AWS. So, why do you think you require
a transit gateway
and what problem transit gateway solves?
Or maybe why transit gateway is required
at the first place because we have VPC
peering, right? If you have to connect
multiple VPCs within the AWS,
how transit gateway is beneficial as
compared to VPC peering?
So, let us consider if you have to
connect only two VPCs then VPC peering
is fine. But let's say if you want to
connect more than two VPCs, let's say
five or 10 VPCs then you have to connect
then you have to do VPC peering among
all VPCs. That is from A to B, A to C, A
to D. Okay, it cannot it is not
transitive. But transit gateway is hub
and spoke model. That means you can just
have one transit gateway in the middle
which can be connected to all the VPCs
and then all the VPCs can communicate
with each other using the transit
gateway.
Okay. So, you mentioned that VPC peering
is cheap as compared to transit gateway
when it comes to peering only or
connecting only two VPCs. Why do you
think it is so?
So, the data transfer via VPC peering is
cheaper than the data transfer via
transit gateway.
Okay. It depends on the data transfer.
Just configuration
is fine.
Okay. Okay, fine.
Husain, have you worked with disaster
recovery
in your experience?
Yes, I worked with it. Okay, so suppose
I have
an e-commerce website. Okay, and I want
to design a disaster recovery solution
for this e-commerce website.
And it the disaster recovery
region should be geographically isolated
from the primary one.
So, what would be the solution that you
will design?
Sure. So, first of all I would
get to know that how much critical is
your application and I would ask that if
you're okay with some
time of downtime or no downtime is
required. Okay, accordingly I will set
up a solution. So, let's go through
those scenarios. In the first scenario
where you say that
we can handle some downtime but we need
a cheaper solution. So, at that time on
that we would go with the backup and
recovery process where we are backing up
all the EKS cluster and the application
and the RDS and we are ready whenever
the whenever the disaster happens. We
will spin up the new EKS, we will spin
up the new RDS in the
DR region and we and once the
application is up we will route the
traffic to the new region. So, in this
scenario there might be some downtime
but it is a cheaper solution.
Coming to the next solution where you
want less amount of downtime in that
scenario what we can have is we can have
a read replica in your another region.
For RDS we can have EKS cluster there
but we'll have scaled down all the nodes
to zero.
That means your application is not
running but it is ready whenever the
disaster happens. So, in less amount of
time we just have to spin up the nodes
of the EKS and then the we will route
the traffic. And in the third scenario
where you say that your application is
very much critical, you have to have the
application up all the time. You cannot
afford any downtime. At that time in the
DR region we will spin up the full
scaled EKS. We will have RDS as a read
replica. And at the time of disaster we
will have failover policies in our route
53. So, whenever the application load
balancer is not giving the perfect
health check in the primary region then
all the traffic will be diverted to the
secondary region and without any
downtime the users won't face any issues
and the all the traffic will be diverted
to the DR region.
So, this is how we would set up a DR.
Okay. So, just in case if you want to
if you want to support this particular
e-commerce website globally, okay. So,
imagine this this will be accessed from
US as well as India, okay.
And
the latency should be also very minimum,
right? If someone from India tries to
access
it should be accessible from the nearby
data center and similarly with AWS. Oh,
sorry. Similarly with
the US. Okay, so in that case how will
you design a solution? Um
Because
I also want to separate the rights,
okay. So,
the database also needs to be separate
from each other. So, in that case how
will you support a
maybe both the regions at one time?
Okay. Sure. So, for that we would also
make use of CDN like CloudFront which is
a global service. So, it will help us to
serve the static content. And [snorts]
we will use global global load balancer
so that any request coming from the
specific region it will be handled in
that particular region itself. And
talking about database we will have read
replicas in all the regions where from
where the traffic will be coming from.
And also to reduce latency we will we
can use
elastic cache or Redis to for caching
the data in that in those specific
regions. So, this is how we will
maintain the lowest latency and the
users can
get your get their data from the nearest
data center.
Okay. So, the CDN will take care of your
front end. The elastic cache will cache
your database queries but still it will
not support multiple rights, right? So,
it needs to be some kind of a global
table solution to make sure this
happens. That's okay. Not a problem.
So, basically you have worked with
compute, networking, databases and
storage, all right? So, can you name few
security best practices in each and
every area that you can think of?
Okay. So, starting from networking I
would say that make use of AWS services
like AWS shield is there then AWS WAF is
there to have specific rules
so that whatever requests are coming in
that
we can authenticate first and then move
ahead. We can enable AWS flow logs to
trace all the requests which are
flowing through VPC.
These are the things that we can think
of in networking part. Second, talking
about compute and storage so I would say
whatever RDS are getting created or
whatever EBS are getting created those
should be encrypted with a encryption
key.
And
we'll also make sure that we back up
those
RDS and EBS volumes.
Next, we'll make sure to enable all the
cloud CloudTrail logs and we can also
configure few AWS configs config rules
so that if any misconfigurations are
done in our AWS environment then we can
set up few lambda functions or we can
set up few events to correct those
things.
Okay. And apart from that the monitoring
is something that we'll take into
consideration that is AWS uh
CloudWatch logs. So, and also we will we
will we can set alarms for
any issues. So, if any database goes
down or if any
CPU reaches to high limit then we should
be notified about that so that we can
immediately take
any action against it.
So,
yeah, I think these are the things that
I can think of right now.
Okay. Okay, so this this is good for a
enterprise grade customer, right? So,
having shields, WAFs. All these all
these things are very costly, right? So,
if
if there is a conservative customer,
he mentions to you that Husain, I just
have to keep the lights on. I have to
ensure my infrastructure is secured
enough. I do not have a budget to kind
of
as you like as you know right security
is very costly right so Yes. In that
case, what are the bare bare minimum
things that you would do to keep your
cloud secure?
Okay, got it. So for those bare minimum
things can come like security group
rules it should be
managed with the lowest access possible
with the granular access. It shouldn't
be open to all. Second NSCL we can also
configure on the subnet level.
Next is maintaining the granular access
while providing any policies in IM rules
and also if it's a small based company
then we will managing we will be
managing access management. So whatever
the rules that we have assigned to the
users those policies also should be
minimized like if we are using IM
identity center that we manage in the
permission sets. So those things also
should be minimized. We should have
rules for a couple of teams and we
should give them access accordingly.
And apart from that mean one main thing
that we can
have is to deploy anything using
automation only. There shouldn't be any
manual configurations done in
AWS. Every no one should have any manual
access. This is something is a very best
practice that we can follow. That any
DevOps if you need any infrastructure so
you reach out to your DevOps team and
they will create a Terraform code and
then they will deploy it and then you
can access it. So these are some things
that small grade application small grade
company can take into consideration.
Okay, okay. So there is one security
best practice where you keep your
databases in a private subnet right? But
imagine that
there is a scenario where we need to
keep our database in a public subnet
because some other third party has to
access it. Or maybe basically I want to
make my database accessible to a certain
third party.
So how will you extend access without
compromising on the overall security?
So
There are a couple of ways of accessing
your RDS that is one of the ways using
your traditional user ID and password.
Second way is to also make use of I
I am database authentication. So this is
where your you can create your I am role
and that I am role only can access those
database.
So this is something that also you can
configure it after keeping your database
into your public subnet.
And then also you will attach a security
group rule to your RDS. Make sure that
we are not opening the port to all
all of the internet but we'll make sure
to add that specific IP only to get
through the database.
And apart from that we can also enable
the TLS communication in transit so that
any request coming to your database
should be via SSL certified only or else
it shouldn't get through your database.
So I think these are the configurations
that we can do.
Okay. So if you have an EC2 instance
okay and
there is a vulnerable package installed
in your EC2 instance.
AWS provides one service which can be
installed or the agent can be installed
and it can
give you what kind of package is
vulnerable to what kind of CV.
So do you know what service is that?
I think AWS inspector is one of the
service which will scan all the
resources that you have in AWS and it
will show the vulnerabilities.
Okay, okay, okay fine.
Have you worked with well architected
framework?
Yes, I worked with that. Okay, can you
list down all the pillars and maybe
summarize each one of them?
Sure. So there are six pillars.
Initially there were five pillars then
sustainability was also added. So there
are six pillars that
based on which you should architect your
a framework. Okay, so first
pillar is like
cost is there, security is there, then
operational excellence is there, then
performance is there and reliability is
there and sustainability is there. So
these are the six pillars
which will help you to design an
architecture.
Talking about each pillar I'll just
brief each one of them. So let's say
performance we are talking about that
means what AWS tells you to select your
specific instances, select your specific
RDS which which is aligned with your
application because they there are
multiple AWS instance families, there
are multiple AWS instance types then you
might not know which one to select. So
that framework helps you to select that
specific instance, that specific RDS.
Next coming on to operational
excellence. So there are multiple AWS
services which will help you to develop
your and deploy your architecture. That
is like AWS CICD is there, then backups
are there. So operational operationally
also you can be very much clear on that.
Then talking about performance. So again
it comes like which all services that
you are using, which services will be
best for your application, which
instance type you are selecting, what
what services you are selecting so those
should be optimized.
Next talking about reliability we can
have we have multi multi AZ availability
zones. We have a disaster recovery, we
have backups and recovery. So that there
shouldn't be any concerns whether data
is gone or not.
And
next talking about security so
credibility, integrity and any threat
detection those things are also managed
by AWS.
So we just have to enable those services
and integrate those services in our
application.
And sustainability
is something that AWS takes care.
It depends on which are the instances
that we are spinning up then
it should be sustainable. So this is
something that mostly AWS takes care of
it.
Okay.
Okay, have you worked with cross account
like you have multiple AWS accounts and
suppose you want to access a particular
KMS key
from
one particular source account to a
destination account right? So have you
worked with this kind of a setup where
you have a maybe one example would be
KMS another could be S3. So you have a
source
EC2 instance in in some other account
and you want to access a S3 bucket. So
how do you facilitate that connectivity?
So one example would be your KMS and the
other one could be S3. So what what is
the configuration that is required to do
that or enable that connectivity?
Sure. So you for this we will use STS
that is
a service token. And how will we do is
let's say there is an AWS
account A and account B and your EC2 is
in account A wants to access S3 in
account B. So in your IM role of account
A we will mention the policy of STS to
assume a role and ARN of the role of
account B we will mention there in the
policy. And in the account B the role we
will mention inside the trust policy
we'll mention the ARN of account A so
that the account A can assume a role in
account B and all the policies let's say
I want to access S3 in account B then in
account B IM role only I will allow the
access inside the policies so that IM
role of account A can assume a role in
account B and then it can access the S3
bucket get or put objects whatever
role want to do.
Okay, so while establishing this
particular connectivity did you face any
issues
in your past
any experience with connectivity
failures?
And what was the issue like and how did
you resolve those?
Yes. Cross account access is tricky
right?
Most of the times it doesn't work in the
first attempt when it comes to multiple
environments, multiple services.
So anything that comes to your mind that
that particular issue was for a long
time and you figured out anything that
comes to your mind?
Yes, regarding the KMS key only because
that is not just
read KMS key that you have to give but
you also have to give extra
read access to the policies in account B
as well.
I'm not able to recall what's those
specific read and get access you have to
add but those are the things also
policies you have to add it. And also
when you are trying to access any S3
bucket and if it's a cross account then
you also have to mention the inside the
bucket policies that this is the role
which will be which should be allowed to
do
access on the S3. So bucket policies
also we have to take into consideration
that.
Okay. Have you
hosted a website on S3?
Yes.
Yeah, we have static website on S3. Do
you remember what suppose I have a
domain abc.com and I want to host it on
S3.
So
can you recollect what kind of
configurations or what kind of steps you
have to do to make sure that website is
publicly publicly available
and deployed on S3?
Yeah, I think we also have to make use
of
CloudFront
in front of
S3 that we can mention the
this ARN of S3 and
there should be an index.html file in S3
and we have to mention that specific
file to be accessed to do.
Okay.
Anything else that comes to your mind or
that is it?
>> [clears throat]
>> Yeah, actually I don't remember that cuz
it I have done it long back.
Okay. And no, no, no worries, no
worries. So we spoke about security,
right? What kind of best practices we
have to follow in terms of cloud in
terms of compute, in terms of network,
in terms of storage and database.
So I have a another question on similar
lines.
It would be with respect to cost, okay?
So if a customer says that if most of
the customers nowadays are cost
sensitive, right? They are burning a lot
of cost behind infrastructure and
on top of their mind there is always
everything related to cost, right? So
maybe as a cloud engineer, what would be
your suggestions or what would be or
what would you implement in your cloud
infrastructure to make sure that your
customer is happy and you
implement a lot of FinOps or cloud
cost optimization solutions. Or it can
be on any part. It can be like similar
to security, it can be on compute, it
can it can be on security, databases,
what not.
So just wanted to understand your
perspective on cost.
Sure. So I work with healthcare domain
clients where the compliances and
security, these are the two main pillars
that they have to work on. So and also
be it enterprise level solution or be it
a new application new company, but
everyone has to be cost sensitive.
Now let's So I am definitely responsible
for
how the cost management is to be done.
So how I would look at it look at it is
first I'll make sure that the compliance
and security, these two things are not
compromised whenever I am trying to
reduce the cost. Now there are a lot of
things that I'll go through. First is
I'll check that what is the service
which is costing the highest for the AWS
account. And then I'll see if we can
minimize it or if we can have
alternative of it.
Second
if I know that these are the instances
we will be using for long terms, then
definitely we'll ask to get a reserved
instances and we can also pay the money
up front so that will be way cheaper for
us.
And we can also use spot instances for
the
for the task like bad jobs are going on.
So if any interruption is there, then
also it's fine for the developers. So
I'll make sure that uh
we use those. Next there are a lot of
updates coming from AWS itself. Let's
say recently they said that GP2 was
available, but now GP3 is also available
and they suggest shift your traffic to
from GP2 to GP3. It will give high
performance and it's cheaper as well. So
I'll make sure to integrate those
solutions
to my to change instance types and see
what intensive instances we are using
and are they required or not because
instances are like GPU intensive, IOPS
intensive, memory intensive and these
are the specific families there and
instance types are there. So if we can
switch from instance type like say T3A
T3 to T3A
because T3A is cheaper, but the
configurations are the same. So if those
are the scenario, then I'll
hop on to that.
Next we definitely take backups of RDS,
we definitely take backups of EBS. So
what is what is the retention of the
those backups?
If you are taking if you are keeping it
for longer time which is not required,
so I'll minimize the those retention.
Then in storage classes we have storage
in S3. So are we keeping it in which
class? If we know that this particular
storage is not required, then we can
keep it in glacier class or archive
class.
These are the things that I'll do and
I'll also make use of the AWS services
like AWS cost explorer and AWS trusted
advisor. So these are the services which
suggest us on how we can save cost.
So yeah, so these are the things that
comes to my mind as of now.
Is trusted advisor free?
No, I think you have to pay for it.
Okay, okay. So you mentioned that
if [clears throat] there are any bad
jobs, you can use a spot instance, okay?
So suppose I have a scenario where at
11:30 p.m. I want to run a job
which will fetch some data from the
database and massage data and put it on
some other data pipeline, right?
So in this scenario, will you still use
a spot?
So it depends. batch bad jobs, right? So
this is kind of a bad job, right?
Or maybe
a particular bad job which needs to be
done at a particular time. So
will you still run a spot is is the
question.
So let's see how much time your spot
instance is taking first of how much
time your bad job is taking and also if
it is not completed, are there any
retries available? So if retry is there,
then definitely you can use a spot
instance.
If it completes the job, then it's fine.
If it doesn't complete the job, if there
are any interruptions there and then if
you can rerun your bad job, then also
then it's fine. You can use spot
instance because it will create a new
instance and it will run through it.
Okay. What if that particular instance
type is not available in that region?
So I think there are a lot of
alternative
instance types available or I'll also
switch if instance family
if required because lower higher
instance type is still cheaper than an
on-demand instance that we take. So I'll
again measure the cost. If it's cheaper,
then we can use those things.
Okay. No worries.
So have you worked with infrastructure
as a code
in your experience, right? So
in AWS there is cloud formation, right?
And we have Terraform as well, okay? So
out of the two,
which one is more suitable
for you or maybe in under what
circumstances you will choose cloud
[snorts] formation versus Terraform or
Terraform versus cloud formation? So
just wanted to understand your thought
process behind
both the technologies.
Sure. So I feel Terraform provides a lot
of functionalities be it just for AWS or
it is also multi-cloud and mostly on the
enterprise level we use a Terraform even
though we have to deploy everything on
the AWS only because it provides like
S3
state file and also there are a lot of
it multi-cloud support is there. Then
modularized code is there. That is one
code you can use it multiple times for
multiple environments. You don't have to
reuse the code
rewrite the code. So these
functionalities are provided by
Terraform. So mostly I would prefer
Terraform over cloud formation even
though when you want to deploy
everything on the AWS. But there might
be a few situations where you go with
cloud formation like one of the major
functionality that cloud formation has
is if any new service comes to AWS, it
will take a bit of time to have it have
that code on Terraform. But the cloud
formation will have it immediately. So
if you if you are on a project where any
new service that comes to
comes to AWS and you have to automate
it, then I think you should go with the
cloud formation.
Also cloud formation is very much uh
easy when it comes for creating a code
in
AWS. Let's say if you want to create a
lambda function. So in Terraform there
is a long process to write a
Python code, then you have to push the
Python code up and then you have to
create a lambda function. But in cloud
formation that is also easy.
So these are the few functionalities
where you might choose cloud formation,
but
I if you ask me, then I would prefer
Terraform only.
Okay. So you mentioned about
multi-cloud, right? One of the key
benefits of using Terraform over cloud
formation is clearly the multi-cloud or
cloud agnostic abilities. But imagine
you you have a dedicated infrastructure
only on AWS. It does not have any other
cloud provider or on premises or
wherever.
Will you still choose Terraform or
you'll go ahead with cloud formation?
I would still choose Terraform because
multi-cloud is one of the
functionalities. There are the
functionalities as well like say a
modularized code is there. The community
of Terraform is way huge. If any issues
that you face, then you will be able to
figure out
way easier. And if you have multiple
environments that you have to deploy, if
you have multiple accounts that you have
to deploy, you can do it in just one
directory of the Terraform file. So
those are a lot of functionalities
provided by Terraform. So
that's why I would still prefer
Terraform.
Okay. Okay. So during the initial
conversation you mentioned about load
balances, right? During the highly
available question. So in AWS there are
multiple types of load balances, right?
What are those and under what
circumstances you will use which load
balancer?
Okay. So AWS provide three types of load
balances, application load balancer,
network load balancer and gateway load
balancer.
And there was a classic load balancer
which is which was which is depreciated
right now. So talking about application
load balancer, if you have pathway
routing, if you have host based routing
and [snorts]
for application use case mostly you we
use application load balancer because it
works on layer 7 of OSI model that is
application layer and um
it will
mostly route your traffic to your target
groups and EC2 instances.
Okay. And then next is network load
balancer. So, network load balancer is
used where you have to serve your
traffic with very low latency
and uh
the for example you would use network
load balancer in trading platforms where
millisecond is also very much important
and you cannot expect any delay on your
request. So, in those terms you would
use network load balancer. Also,
functionality that NLB provides is you
can attach a IP to it, elastic IP to it.
And the third load balancer is net
gateway load balancer. So, gateway load
balancer mostly comes in terms of
security because it integrates well with
your API gateway and um
the uh WAF as well. And it is mostly
used in financial sector where your
authorization is more important than
reaching out reaching to the
application. So, whenever a request
comes and then gateway load balancer is
responsible to
check if the request is authentic
or authentic or not and then then only
it will forward it to the application.
So, that's when you use gateway load
balancer.
Okay. Okay.
So, if you want to deploy your
serverless applications, right? You can
use maybe API Gateway and Lambda, right?
So, Yeah. uh
What is the difference or maybe when you
would use an API Gateway
versus when you would use a
application load balancers?
Any particular use cases that things
that comes to your mind where API
Gateway is more suited or load balancer
is more suited?
Yeah. So, let's say if you want to if
your APIs are transferring only inside
the VPC and those are simple APIs and
the path-based routing or host-based
routing will work and at that time you
would use application load balancer
itself.
But if your APIs also have to be
authenticated, those are coming from
third-party APIs and you also have to
request send your request to third-party
third-party tools. Uh so, in those
scenarios you would use API Gateway. Uh
API Gateway also supports DDoS
protection. It also supports
TLS by default. There are a lot of
configurations that you can do in terms
of security in API Gateway. So, in those
scenarios you would go with API Gateway,
but if anything that you want to request
inside the inside your VPC, so then I
would suggest to go with the application
load balancer.
Okay.
So, uh
suppose your application is deployed on
completely on AWS, right? It has Route
53, it has load balancers, it has auto
scaling groups. It can have a EKS
cluster or ECS cluster. It will have RDS
instances. Suppose user users are
reporting failures in your application,
okay? It can be any kind of a failure.
We just got a
uh message from one of our customer that
your application is not working.
So,
what would be your next steps as a cloud
engineer, okay? To investigate the issue
and how do you remediate that particular
issues?
Okay. So, first thing I would check is
what changed. When the application was
running, was there any deployment done?
And after that the application is not
running or if any configuration has been
changed, I'll first check the pipelines
if anyone has run the pipeline, if any
infrastructure has been deployed or
application has been deployed. So, first
I will check that if those are the
things then it will be easier for us to
catch hold of the issue and we can
revert it back.
But let's say if there are no
deployments done, then I'll go to the
like EKS is there, then I'll first check
the logs of each and every component.
I'll start with EKS. I'll see if the pod
is running or not, if the application is
active or not. Then I would check the
databases are active or not. Has anyone
stopped it or if are there any kind of
those issues.
Next I would also see the logs the flow
logs which are going through.
We have also monitoring in place,
observability in place.
We have health checks in place. So, we
will check that which health check is
failing. Your ELB is not working or your
database is not working.
And the most probably I'll
get a hold of the
get hold of that specific issue and then
I'll first see if a new application was
if a new version was deployed, then I'll
revert it back so that the application
is stable. My first
point of uh
uh
My first thing would be to make the
application stable and then figure out
that what was the issue. So, I'll first
revert it back and then I'll see through
the logs
that what's the issue and then I'll try
to again redeploy it on the staging and
dev environment first and then again
move to production.
Okay. So, Hussein, we spent a lot of
time on AWS. So, I think let's
dive
uh deep into the other DevOps tools,
right? Like Docker, Kubernetes,
Terraform. So, just wanted to understand
from your end about from AWS what kind
of other DevOps tools you are well
versed with and
what's your experience on all the tools
like?
So, I'm well versed with Terraform and
Kubernetes because that's our day-to-day
task that I have to do. And also
creating CI/CD pipelines. That is also
something that I do on daily basis using
GitHub Actions and AWS CodePipeline. And
also creating and pushing Docker images
to ECR and deploying those things.
Okay. So, do you create Docker images or
you get Docker images from the
developers? You are just responsible to
the CI responsible for the CI/CD?
No, I create as well. We get on a call
with the developer. Mostly I only create
and yeah.
The requirement let's say
let's say there is a requirements.txt
file, those things will be given by the
developer, but we usually create a
lightweighted image.
Okay. Okay. In that case, I want to
understand uh what are the some what are
the some uh Docker best practices that
you follow?
Or in terms of image creation.
All right. So, as I said, we have to
create lightweight Docker image. It
should be optimized. It should not be a
very heavyweight.
So, for that we first we should use is
the it should be a multi-stage build
where initially in the first stage you
are building the application and then
you are utilizing that artifact which
was built by the older image and then
you build your final image and then you
run the container. So, that is one thing
to
have multi-stage builds. And even in
that you have to make sure that you are
using lightweight image.
One of the and also you shouldn't be
using like let's say Alpine is one of
the lightweight image, but you shouldn't
be using like alpine.latest because
there might be any new configurations
done. So, there shouldn't be any
surprises for you. So, always make sure
that we are if the base image we are
using with a specific tag only.
And then definitely we will move ahead.
We will update the tags. It's
we will go through the document what are
the new updates in that specific image
and then we'll update it.
Next best practice that we follow is to
not run the container with the root
access. So, we will create a specific
user in that image and then we will run
the Docker image with that specific user
having the access to that specific
folder only.
And we'll make sure we also make sure
that whenever we create a Docker image,
we also document it so that if any new
DevOps engineer comes or even the
developer comes and watches that image,
they should know that why
every command is written for what
purpose.
So, these are the things that I would
make sure while creating a Docker image.
Okay. And where do you host your Docker
images?
Right now we host it on ECR, AWS ECR.
Okay. ECR. And uh
how do you control how many number of
images are there in ECR because it can
grow, right?
I have been working with a customer
where some of the DevOps engineers have
kept like unlimited number of ECR images
and their
ECR usage or bill has been shot up.
So, what kind of
practices you follow to ensure that the
ECR images are
not often and only required whichever
images are required are there in the
repository. How do you ensure that?
Correct. Yes. So, that is a case that
was a case with our organization as well
because developers would add a tag and
it will
they would push even for testing. They
would push a lot of Docker images. So,
we have couple of Lambda functions that
will trigger on
daily basis to check how many images are
there and the latest latest five to
seven images it will uh make sure that
it is there in ECR, but the below the
older images it will
Lambda functions we don't just do it for
ECR, we do it for all the resources as
well for EC2 and RDS if they are running
on the night time as well. So, it will
make sure that during night time uh we
scale down those resources because in in
the night time no one is using that.
And similarly we do it for ECR as well.
Okay.
Okay, fine.
So, one of the challenges that I face um
in in our orgs, basically developer says
that this particular Docker images are
working fine or absolutely fine in our
local machines. But when we deploy it uh
on maybe AWS environment, it doesn't
work, okay? So, this is a very typical
and a common scenario. Okay. So, how do
you ensure that whatever Docker image is
created on the developer machine is
working as is on on the ECS cluster or
EKS cluster?
Yeah, correct. So, this was actually a
major issue and that's why also Docker
came into picture that uh system things
are working on my system but not working
on another system. So, Docker is one of
the solution that uh it should work on
every system. But one of the solution
that even I faced is
uh there can be a port issue. That means
you are opening your port in your uh
local system, but that is already being
used on EKS or a Docker EC2 that you're
using. So, those things we also need to
take into consideration that
what how you are deploying it on your
local machine and is the same thing is
the same way that how we are deploying
it on EC on EKS or on uh contain on EC2.
So, that is one thing that we would got
on get on a call with a developer and
check that.
And uh
apart from that uh
we'll also uh check like let's say the
port that you're opening is also open in
the security group or not. So, those
requests coming to uh
should be allowed there. So, that can be
a one of the port issue and second is
the tags that you're giving to your
image, is it repeated or not? Because
that might be a case that you're pushing
a different image and you're uh pulling
different image from uh on the EKS or on
the uh EC2. So, those things I would see
first.
Okay. Another common issue that we see
is whatever images that are pushed onto
ECR, right? Nowadays, we work with a lot
of enterprise customer and
they do a security scanning on those
images, right?
And
no images are like perfect, right? There
are a lot of vulnerabilities as well
because
developers install a lot of packages
from here and there. DevOps engineer
also
installs a lot of packages from here and
there.
So,
do you also take care of the overall
security of the Docker image or is
someone else who takes care?
Uh no, so we only take care and it is
not that developer will directly push
the image to ECR. We have CICD pipeline
set up. So, how the process looks like
is the developer will push the code into
GitHub, then the pipeline will trigger
and there are multiple jobs multiple
tasks. So, initially what it will do is
it will first check the code using a
tool called like uh SonarQube. So, it
will first uh check that and then it
will go to the next stage where it will
uh it will go to the build stage where
it will create an image and then
afterwards we can uh we also have our
tool like Trivy to check that the Docker
image.
>> Sorry, the tool like? Trivy.
Oh, Trivy.
>> Trivy, yeah. [clears throat] So, it will
scan the Docker image and then it will
prepare report and give to show it to
the developer and then if everything
works well, then only it will push to
ECR.
Okay. And also we have one the best
practice is to uh ask developers to
check all the security scanning tools on
your local itself and then push your
code to uh GitHub so that uh the
the time is not wasted and the pipelines
are also not uh keep on running. So,
those things also we make sure to have
that this is a practice that
>> will you ensure the developer does the
scanning on his local first? And then
because you still need to have some kind
of control over the pipeline, right? You
cannot trust the developer that he will
scan the scan his code and then push the
image push push the code onto the GitHub
repository, right? As a DevOps engineer
or a DevSecOps engineer, we still have
to enforce certain controls in the
pipeline, right? So, Correct, correct.
That we definitely have, but how
developers does is they just test it on
the pipeline. So, what I am asking
developers to do is first test it on
local and then push it on the pipeline.
Because when you run the instances, that
also incurs cost. So, if a developer is
pushing 10 times just for one change,
uh that is not practical uh for the
organization. So, it's a best practice
that we follow. It's not that the
developers will check and push the code
and it will go to ECR. Uh those checks
will be done in pipelines, but uh just
to avoid that multiple runs of pipeline,
we ask the developers to check it on the
local as well and then push the code.
Okay. Okay, fine. So,
this is uh with respect to security, but
if you have to uh reduce the
overall size of the Docker image, so
what kind of measures you take?
So, we will go through the Docker image.
We will see that what are the files we
are copying and
as I said that uh we are you we have to
use the lightweight image only,
lightweight base image only and uh using
multi-stage build also helps us to
optimize the Docker image. It also helps
us to bring the size of the image down.
So, these are the policies these are the
practices that we follow to have the
uh lightweight image
created.
>> Okay.
All right. So, this was about Docker.
So, let's move to Kubernetes. So, you
have talked a lot of a lot of stuff
about Kubernetes, your experience with
Kubernetes, EKS and in general, right?
So,
one thing that I'm interested in is uh
how do you
uh update your EKS clusters? Okay, so
what kind of
uh steps you take
um
to update update your EKS cluster? How
do you make make sure that your
uh applications are not down? Uh it is
like a zero down downtime upgrade. So,
how do you do that?
Sure. So, before upgrading any EKS
cluster, we have to have a lot of
prerequisites and we follow that first.
So, we first create a manual on how what
are the steps that we will be following.
Next, we will also go through the
release notes on which the Kubernetes
version we are going to. Are there any
depreciated APIs or not?
Uh the application that we have deployed
are is compatible with the Kubernetes
version that you are upgrading to.
So, these are the few steps for you few
prerequisites that we follow. We also
make sure that the Terraform uh the
deployment of the application and the
deployment of the
uh EKS is both done through pipelines.
So, any anytime if you want to roll
back, it can be done as soon as
possible. We don't have to wait for
that. We also take the backup of the
application using a tool like Velero
uh and EKS
also. So, after doing all these
prerequisites, first we will test the
upgrades in the lower environments and
then only we will move to higher
environments. Now, talking about the
uh upgrade, so how we do it is uh we use
EKS so that the mostly the upgrade is
managed by uh the upgrade of control
plane is managed by EKS only and then we
one by one cordon each node and we make
sure that the workload is transferred to
the another node and then we upgrade the
specific node and then we uncordon that
node. So, this is a process that we
follow for all all nodes and after that
if we have any add-ons
uh that also we have to upgrade. So, we
do that afterwards.
And uh so mostly this is how we follow
the process. And
Just in case the the upgrade fails,
okay? So, imagine that you are moving
from 1.x to 1.x's x's or some other
version.
And
if it fails, okay? If if the application
stops working,
what are your next steps?
Yes, so as I said that uh because of
that in the prerequisite we take backup
of EKS, we take uh we are ready with the
deployment of application. Because once
you upgrade, you cannot downgrade the
EKS, be it node or be it cluster. So,
first of all, of course we'll
troubleshoot uh that what's the issue.
Uh if it is a version issue, if it is a
API issue, uh a specific small a small
service is not working because of that
the whole application is down, can we do
something about it and uh we can resolve
it or not. And if those things are not
possible, then definitely we have to
skip spin up another EKS cluster in the
older version. We have to deploy our
application again for the older version
and first we have to make the
application ready and stable so that no
users are being hampered. And then we
will uh check that what was the issue in
the deployment process.
And then uh we can take up some
decision.
Okay. Okay.
Uh so, have you worked with uh stateful
applications on Kubernetes?
Yes.
Okay, can you give an example of a
stateful application that you worked on
Kubernetes?
Yeah, so there was a POC that we have
created where the uh we had to deploy
the application on EKS and we had to use
the MongoDB as database. So, for using
that MongoDB as database, we made use of
stateful set and uh there we created
couple of pods and uh we created
persistent volume for that and
uh so that was one of the uh
scenario where we used stateful sets.
Okay, but in AWS, you have a managed
service called document DB. Which which
provides
MongoDB support, right? Yeah. So why why
you wanted it to be deployed on a
Kubernetes cluster?
Okay, so that was a requirement to have
it deployed on the Kubernetes cluster,
but let's say if you ask me that where
it should be deployed, then of course
third like AWS provided solution is
better than deploying it on EKS. But
they wanted a specific POC on if
everything is deployed on EKS, then how
it will work.
Okay, but you didn't question them?
Maybe as a DevOps engineer, you should
start questioning as well.
Yeah, but when it's a business
requirement, they are very much stick to
it. And also they wanted to check. So
it was a POC. Yeah. Okay, one of the
reason could be cost because
AWS managed services are very costly.
Okay, so there was a customer where they
wanted Kafka to be deployed
on Kubernetes versus Kafka as a managed
service, right? EKS is a managed service
from AWS, but they were reluctant to
move from Kubernetes to
a managed service because of the cost.
Correct.
>> So cost is one of the biggest concern.
Because
I'm of a opinion that Kubernetes and EKS
should be mostly stateless. Okay?
>> Yeah. So anything that comes to
with respect to state, it should be
moved to a managed service or outside
the Kubernetes cluster, but yeah. There
are different opinions, but I still
believe it should be all stateless.
Correct.
So you have worked a lot on deployments,
right?
There are a lot of deployment
strategies, right? So I'm more
interested in uh does Kubernetes support
a blue/green deployment?
If yes, so what is the configuration
like? How will you deploy a particular
application with blue/green?
Sure. So Kubernetes definitely support
blue/green deployment, canary
deployment, and rolling update
deployment, which is the default one.
Talking about the blue/green deployment,
the configuration how I would do is I
would
first create the upgraded version of
application. Let's say I have a specific
namespace and that I have to update that
application. So newer version of
application, I will deploy first the
deployment file of the whole new
application in that specific namespace,
and then I will configure on the ingress
file that how much traffic should be
diverted to the newer
version of EKS.
Newer version of that application.
So you can manage the configuration on
the ingress file that uh
let's say if 100 100% of your traffic is
going to the older version, and then you
can just
update that annotations on your ingress,
so that the whole traffic will be
diverted to the newer version
using by labels and selectors.
>> [clears throat]
>> Okay.
Yeah. So this is one of the way that you
can do. Also
you can make use of Argo Rollouts. So
that is also something that
you can do. So everything will be
managed by the CRD that you create in
Argo Rollouts. So there you have to
mention all the configurations, and you
can also test it
there and there itself.
Okay. So can you list down few best
practices with respect to Kubernetes and
not EKS or AWS? I wanted to understand
specifically
with respect to sorry, Kubernetes.
>> Kubernetes. Yeah. Yes.
>> So it can be cost, it can be security,
any anything that comes to your mind.
What are the best practices that you
follow as a DevOps engineer?
Sure. So one of the best practice that
you should follow is to mention the
request and limits in your pods that how
much CPU and memory it will be
utilizing. Second
thing is
you also
should make use of the configuration
systems like secrets and config map to
hold your secrets and hold your
variables rather than mentioning it in
the
variables environment variables or
you're hardcoding it into application.
Next,
also make use of a monitoring your EKS
cluster. So our first CloudWatch might
do that. You can install that agent or
if you want any custom metrics, you want
to create any custom logs of your
application. So in those scenarios, you
will use Prometheus and Grafana as well.
It is very easy to deploy it using Helm,
and you can also make use of
PromQL to query a specific metric, and
you can visualize it on the dashboard.
So that if any happenings,
you you are ready with it.
Next, you can again using this
Prometheus and Grafana, you can also set
up alerts. So if any node is taking like
more than 80% of usage, then you can get
an alert if you don't want to like auto
auto scale or if you have an auto scale
stop at five nodes, but even beyond five
nodes if they are requesting even even
if that even if then your pods are not
getting created. So at that time you
might get notified. So those are the
things that you can configure.
And talking about security, you also
make use of R back. You make use of
IRSA service accounts you can create. So
that
you can give access to your specific pod
to
specific resource and not the whole
cluster to the to those resources. So
these are the config these are the best
practices I can think of right now using
for Kubernetes.
All right, listen. So you mentioned
about secrets and config maps, right?
But
the secrets that comes with Kubernetes
out of the box,
are they really secrets or you need to
do some more stuff to make sure that
particular
>> [clears throat]
>> configuration is secured?
Because
I think secrets can still be
uh
decoded, right?
Yeah, correct. It is in a base64 format.
Yes, it's base64.
>> So anyone who has access to a Kubernetes
cluster can get that secret. So imagine
I want to connect my application pod to
a database,
and I put that
database password in the secret.
So
how do I make it more secure?
So in that level, what you can do is we
have R back
as well. So we can not give access to
that secret to all the developers. Only
the specific DevOps engineers or only
the let's say manager or tech lead can
have only access to those secrets, and
then you can like fetch it from the AWS
secrets manager, and then you can store
it on that secrets.
Right, yeah, yeah. So AWS secrets
manager is that additional layer of
security that it provides. Even if you
put an R back and you don't use secrets
manager, uh
still can be a problem, right? Because I
want to keep the secret uh
in an external location and not within
the Kubernetes cluster.
Okay,
that is good. So what kind of
troubleshooting scenarios you have faced
in Kubernetes?
A lot of, I would say. Because whenever
you run a pod, there are a lot of
scenarios. Let's say there's a crash
loop back off error or image pull back
off error or it's in the scheduling
state only. It's not getting scheduled
to any pods to any nodes. So there are a
lot of troubleshooting
cases there. And talking about one of
them is like let's say if there's a
crash loop back off error where your pod
is getting restarted again and again. So
at that time, you first have to go
through logs. That is kubectl, you can
describe the logs. Mostly you'll find
the issue there. Or you can describe the
pod. So in that you will find the event
that uh
you because of which reason the pod is
not getting created. So there you can
find the reason, and then you can uh
take a decision on what needs to be
done.
Okay. So at the beginning you mentioned
about ingress, right? Uh so my question
is simple like why do we need ingress at
the first place? Because there is
something called as services as well,
right? In Kubernetes.
So
services are also used to expose your
deployment, your pods, right? To the
external world.
So why did they they needed to create
another construct called as ingress? So
how it is different from services?
Correct. So services can first of all,
internally they can communicate, but if
you want to communicate to a service,
you will need to create a load balancer.
So that the outside
outside user can also
communicate with the with that service.
Now if there are 10 services, and if you
create 10 load balancers, so that will
be a huge cost to the company. So that's
why we make use of controller like
ingress controller. And that also
ingress controller also provides a lot
of functionalities like let's say Nginx
ingress controller is there. So that is
something that you integrate with your
Kubernetes, and you mention all the
routes there. So just by one application
load balancer, and mentioning all those
services routes in your ingress, you can
route your traffic accordingly to the
different services to the different pods
and not have 10 application load
balances for 10 services.
Okay. So, uh
you mentioned about a lot of application
deployment on EKS or Kubernetes, right?
So, what tool uh you use to deploy the
applications?
So, for Kubernetes, we use Argo CD,
which is a GitOps approach uh
to
uh as a continuous deployment in our
CI/CD pipeline.
Okay. So, only Argo CD
uh you use or you use Helm plus Argo CD?
Yeah, it's Helm plus Argo CD. Okay,
because I Yeah, most of the
organizations use Helm and on top of
that they have Argo CD to pull all the
Helm charts and all that stuff. Correct.
So,
uh
Yeah, so Kubernetes also have YAMLs,
right? So, you can basically write a
deployment.yaml, services.yaml, and just
run it. Uh
it's quite simple, right?
Why do you want to add
complexity of having something like a
Helm chart, right?
Why do you need Helm chart?
So, Helm chart is required
uh you can consider it as a package of
your deployment. If you need secrets,
you need deployment, you need replica
set, you need config maps. So, all of
these things what you can do is you can
create a package of it and you can have
values.yaml file to just update the
values there. And the major
functionality of using Helm is you can
use the same configuration in the
different environments. You don't have
to write the YAML files for dev, val,
production. Okay. So, just using one
Helm chart, you can um make use of diff
in different environments and you just
have to update the values.yaml file
depending on the applicate depending on
the environment that you want to deploy.
Mhm. Okay. Uh
Right. Right. Right. So,
there is uh there is a
term or maybe there is a concept called
probes in
uh Kubernetes, right? There are multiple
types of probes.
Uh do you have experience working with
probes or you just know what the probes
are?
Yeah, I have experience. So, in one of
the application, we had a liveness probe
and readiness probe. These are the two
probes that we configured for
>> are they
from each other?
So, liveness probe is something that
will tell that the pod is actively
running. In it's in the running state.
And readiness probe is something that
will tell that uh is the pod ready to
serve traffic or not. For example, uh if
there is a pod you have configured
readiness probe in it and you are and
that pod is trying to fetch queries from
database, but that database is not
working.
Uh the pod is up and running, but it is
trying to fetch query from database,
which is not uh running fine. So, you
config you have logics in your uh how
you would check your
readiness [clears throat] probe and uh
this liveness probe.
Okay. Okay. So, there is a typical
scenario that most of the times we have
faced is we update a particular config
uh
in our Kubernetes cluster,
uh which is added as an environment
variable on your pod definition, right?
And the idea is the the config should
work behind the scenes, right? It should
like I change a config and automatically
it should percolate and the application
should start working, but it doesn't
work like that, okay? So, if if I make a
change to the config, I need to restart
my pod. Okay. So, why do you think that
this is needed? And how will you
overcome this? So, basically uh what I
what I need is if I change the config
uh behind the scenes, my pod should pick
up that latest config.
Correct. Yeah. So, if you It depends on
how you are mapping your config map with
your pod. If you are just mapping it
using the environment variable that is
from ENV, then what pod will do is it
will just fetch the values when the pod
is starting or restarting. But if you
are mapping your config map as a volume
to your pods, that means whenever you
are
updating your config map, then it will
uh take the latest values because now
you have mapped it as a volume and not
just as an environment variable.
But also there might be one scenario
that uh your application is configured
in a way that it will fetch con fetch
values from config map only at the time
of starting the pods. So, in those
scenarios, if the application is
configured like that, then you
definitely have to restart it. But the
solution of mapping it as a volume might
solve the problem.
Okay, but uh what the developers claim
is it requires a code change, right?
Reading it from a environment variable
and reading it from maybe if you add it
as a config map, it needs to be mapped
to a certain path, right?
Yeah. For a developer, it is it is a
change, right? So, that is also one key
consideration that we have to make.
Um
So, that is kind of a tricky situation
for us. Okay. I think that is it for
Kubernetes. I think let's quickly jump
to
Terraform and IAC section. So, we had a
brief conversation on this versus that,
right? Why CloudFormation or why
Terraform? Terraform. Yeah. So, imagine
that you have a
uh enterprise and they have a control
tower or maybe a landing zone where
there are multiple accounts like
15, sorry. 15 to 20 accounts they have.
And they want to uh deploy their entire
infrastructure, their accounts, all new
accounts, all all the underlying
infrastructure using Terraform.
So, I wanted to understand
uh how would you architect uh a
Terraform directory? Basically, imagine
that I'm inside the Terraform directory.
I want to understand what would be the
different folders, what would be the
different files.
Um and the requirement would be there
would be multiple accounts. Under
multiple accounts, there can be multiple
environments as well. Okay. So, consider
and multiple regions as So,
um since it is an enterprise customer,
uh the customer will have multiple
accounts, multiple regions, and multiple
environments. So, consider considering
this requirement, how will you kind of
have a directory structure?
All right. So, as I have the
requirements like there are multiple
accounts, there are multiple
environments, and multiple regions. So,
first I will try to group them. Uh let's
say we group them as environments and uh
accounts. Mhm.
>> directory structure how it would look
like is first I will have uh let's say
there are three environments uh dev,
validation, and production. So, first I
will have three root folders, that is
dev, val, and prod. And inside dev, I
would have directory structure as per
the accounts. Uh you can have account
name or account number. Mhm.
>> So, in dev directory structure, there
will be a small
different directories of the account uh
number. Let's say consider that.
Similarly for val and production.
I would also have a directory of shared
services because there might be an AWS
account where uh there are central
centralized storages are there. So, if
that is also one central
uh account, then I'll have one directory
of that as well. And fourth
directory I will have is for the
modules. So, what I would do is I won't
be writing code for all the uh accounts,
right? So, I'll make use of modules and
module also I'll make sure that either
we are using AWS provided modules or we
are creating local modules as per our
requirement of the organization. And
then I would be calling those modules
like IAM or network because these are
reusable modules in all the accounts.
So, those modules I'll be calling from
the uh AWS the directory structure that
I've said from the accounts.
Mhm.
Okay. Okay.
Uh
so, uh you are working with or maybe
your organization is working with open
source Terraform or the enterprise or
the cloud version?
Currently, we are working with open
source only. Open source. So, do you
face any challenges working with open
source?
Uh right now we don't because we are
managing Let's say uh we are managing
access management using GitHub. We are
storing the remote backend in S3. So,
for now, I'm not facing any specific
challenges, but if we would have used
the enterprise, then these things can be
taken care by enterprise itself.
Okay. So, you mean to say you are using
open source, right? So, suppose if I
have to deploy an EC2 one
um a production environment, okay?
So, you write your code on your local
and directly deploy on the production or
how is the process like?
No. So, if I want to do it on
production, definitely I won't be able
to do that directly. First, I have to go
for like dev, val, and production. And
even let's consider you want to do it in
dev. So, there is a CI/CD pipeline which
is configured where you store the TF
state file in the S3 bucket. So, you
would first push the code, the pipeline
will figure. It will do all the security
scanning, TF lint, FMT, validate, and
then it will do Terraform plan. After
Terraform plan, it will stop and it will
be reviewed by your senior and then uh
if it looks good, then only he will
approve it and then it will deploy it on
post dev environment. Then you have to
raise a change request. You have to go
through the process of approvals for
validation and production. And then in
the production validation, it will be
the same process to push it, uh get the
approval, and then
deploy it. And then you merge your
CR to main.
Okay, but if your customer says that you
have got like 5 minutes and you want to
deploy that infrastructure, so will you
still go through all these iterations?
Uh no. So, if that is a urgent
requirement, then still there will be an
approval process. If the we have all the
approvals, and if you want to do it on
production, then you can run directly
pipeline on production as well. But it
has to go through pipeline process.
Okay. Okay. That is one kind of a
challenge that all the organizations
face who uses like open-source version,
right? When you When it comes to
enterprises, when it comes to
uh sorry, Terraform Enterprise or cloud,
they give you some additional benefits
that OSS doesn't provide, right? So,
Okay. That is kind of a big challenge
for us as well.
So,
uh
while creating
like infrastructure, right? There is
also a lot of secret management
involved, right? So, suppose if you want
to create a database,
or maybe you want to create an EC2, uh
you have to pass your SSH keys, right?
While creating the EC2 instance. If you
want to create an RDS instances, I want
username and password.
So,
where are these secrets stored? Okay, so
how will you make sure that
uh these particular secrets are
safe and not exposed
to the external world.
Correct. So, for let's say if you are
creating any RDS, and we want to add the
username and password there, so either
we would use a random functionality
provided by Terraform, that it would
create a random secret there and there
itself, and then it would
create an RDS, and that random secret
and username and password we'll store it
in the AWS Secrets Manager.
So, this is how mostly we used to do.
Okay. Okay.
But there is a scenario where I don't
want my state file to have any sensitive
information.
Um
this particular random
string will will create that particular
string and store it in the state file,
right?
So, how will you ensure that it doesn't
happen? But
it's okay if you don't know, but that
that will happen, right? Yeah,
definitely. Yeah, so some organizations
will try to keep your Terraform state
file secured and a in a central
location. You mentioned that S3, so that
is good. But they will try to restrict
that particular S3. But there are other
alternatives as well, right? So,
you can still safeguard that particular
thing, and
there are few hard requirements from the
security where
uh they said they say that even it is
okay if you don't automate the entire
infrastructure 100%.
But our password should not be stored
anywhere.
In that case, there are other
alternatives as well, right? So, Yeah,
so if anything
>> Yeah, right. So,
we work with So, there are few
organizations where they are like they
give a little bit of leeway where it's
okay to have secrets in your Terraform
state file. There it is okay, but there
are organizations like banks or highly
regulated industries where they want
each and everything to be
secured, right? They don't care about
automation. Automation is to make our
lives easy, but their job is to keep
everything secure. In that scenario,
what we usually do is some secrets we
create manually using AWS CLI, and we
pass that into the Terraform. Okay.
Okay. So, there is a little bit of
manual stuff involved, okay? But as as
we mentioned that
the organization needs to comply with
100% security, so that is kind of a
uh
adjustment we have to do, or an
arrangement we have to do. But yeah,
there is nothing right or wrong in that.
So, according to what your requirement
or what your customer requirement is, we
have to
uh make changes to our uh
solution. Okay. So, uh
Yeah, so we spoke about Terraform state
as well, right? So, if there are
multiple developers, okay? Like uh
>> [snorts]
>> uh if there are 10 developers or 10
DevOps engineers working on their local,
so how will you ensure, or what is that
particular configuration that ensures
that uh you don't jump onto each other's
work? Terraform state will store it in a
centralized location,
but how do you guarantee that?
So, uh
>> And your changes are not
like you're not overstepping on each
other's work.
Okay. So, we have this uh trunk-based,
first of all, branching strategy that
every all the code should be in GitHub
only.
Second thing is the S3 uh we will be
storing the
uh TF state file in S3 itself. And it
will make sure that it will be locking
the state file whenever one developer is
using. So,
uh and before the next developer does
the apply.
But let's say if two developers are
working in parallelly, and they don't
have to wait for one DevOps engineer to
complete their job. So, in those
scenarios, what we do is we create
workspaces,
and the workspaces work work workspaces
TF state file are in the local only, so
that you can just test your code. You
can do Terraform plan, and you can test
your code. And then if things are
looking well, then you can raise a PR.
So, that at the time of merge, uh there
we will run the main pipeline once
again, and then the actual TF state file
will be updated, and then your code will
be deployed. But before that, if you
want to just test your code, then you
can make use of Terraform workspace.
Okay. So, you mean to say Terraform
workspaces on your local, right? Not the
enterprise or the cloud version.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah, on the local.
Okay. So, do you have any information on
the enterprise version of workspaces,
how they are different from your local?
Uh
Um I'm not I've not much to work with
enterprise-level solution.
>> That that's
uh That that's completely okay.
Uh so, one of the challenges that I face
working with my team is sometimes the
infrastructure fails, right? Your
Terraform fails.
Or there is some or the other thing that
has not worked as per the expectation.
So, how do you ensure that it goes to
the earlier state, or maybe you roll
back?
So, do you do you follow any practices
to roll back your infrastructure
with respect to Terraform, of course?
>> [snorts]
>> Yeah, correct. So, there are definitely
scenarios where your code will pass all
the test cases. It will go through
Terraform plan well, and then at the
time of deployment, it might fail.
So, first of all, things that we need to
check is what are the services that it
created, or what it has destroyed.
Because there might be a possibility
that if partial deployment is done, then
your application might suffer, or any uh
issues might be there.
So, first I will we would check that. If
there is no issues like that, then what
we will do is we would revert back to
the older version older commit, and then
we would run the pipeline. So, that the
deployment is reverted first of all. And
then we would
check that what was the issue, and how
we can resolve it. Again, it should be
done from dev well prod.
Another automation that we can add is as
soon as the Terraform pipeline fails in
the workflow itself, we can mention that
you should check out to your older
version and run the pipeline once again.
So, that we just get notified that the
pipeline is failed, and the older
version is now up and running. Um So,
this is something configuration that can
be done on the workflow end as well.
Okay. Okay. Okay, fine. Thanks, uh sir.
So, I think we have covered AWS, we have
covered Kubernetes, a little bit of
Docker, and Terraform.
So, I wanted to ask you non-technical
questions. Uh okay. So,
uh right now there is a lot of buzz
around AI, right? Um DevOps or developer
jobs are going to cut, or anything else.
So,
uh in your day-to-day activities or
day-to-day
uh work, how much part is driven by AI?
Okay. So, like Hussein works for 8
hours, or maybe he has some some X
number of tasks.
What number is driven by AI, or
uh assisted by AI, and what part Hussein
does?
Correct. So, as we work in enterprise
level, and also in house, uh one of the
thing that we have to maintain is the
documentation of whatever you do.
And uh so, those things
uh for those things, I completely I'm
dependent on AI. I try my level best to
uh ask the AI to create those
documentation, to create all the points.
Uh so, that and it gives in a really
good manner,
so that I can use it.
Second thing, I don't usually use it for
development, because I know that AI
tools hallucinates. It gives wrong
answer very confidently. So, if I have
to create an infrastructure, if I have
to deploy anything, so my first place
would be to go to documentation.
Terraform has very good documentation.
Kubernetes has its own really good
documentation.
So, for development, I usually uh do it
on documentation on official
documentation only. But the problem with
this approach is it will be slow, right?
Uh because I remember creating
infrastructure like I've been working
with Terraform since like
uh 6 to 7 years now like from
2018 or 19 I've been working with
Terraform or maybe CloudFormation for
that matter.
So, when I started to to create a
particular multi layer multi account
landing zone, I had to
uh maybe I I used to take like 15 days
20 days to script an entire landing
zone, right? 10 12 accounts, CloudTrail
configs, multiple EC2 instances, ALBs,
or whatnot.
But uh with um
AI, so I and my team uses a lot of
cursor, okay, and now Anti-Gravity.
So, we can we can create the same
infrastructure in like a couple of days.
Okay. So, I understand that it you you
rightly mentioned that it hallucinates.
The the downsides are already there, but
there are a few benefits as well, right?
So,
imagine 10 to 15 day days of work was
cut down into like 2 days. Correct. Yes.
Uh
but I was able to do that because I had
the experience, right? I was able to
write the correct prompts and if if
if the tool hallucinates or it doesn't
give the required output, I I I was able
enough to make changes to that.
But
uh I think you should start using a
little bit of AI in your workflow. Um I
understand that documentation is correct
or maybe it is the right place to do it,
but
I still believe that uh AI has the
potential. It will not replace the
the entire engineer work, but it it it
can be a good assistance. The problem
right now uh
with the mindset is people are kindly
relying everything on AI.
Yeah, so that that is kind of a problem,
but yeah. Uh maybe
uh you'll get more confidence in AI
and you should start working with tools
like cursor. Do you use any tools like
cursor or
Anti-Gravity or Cloud Load?
No, as of now we don't use any of
>> I I I'll I'll request you to or maybe
recommend you to use cursor. At least
start with cursor, then maybe you can
try other tools. So, you'll certainly
like it. Okay. So, apart from that,
uh you're currently working as a cloud
engineer or a DevOps engineer, right?
Correct.
>> So, what are your aspirations? Like like
in next 5 years, where do you see
yourself? Like you want to continue
doing hands-on um DevOps work or you
want to get into management kind of or
architect level role?
So, what what are your next
5-year plans?
Next uh at least for 3 years I would say
I still want to be a DevOps engineer
hardcore where I have all the technical
knowledge and not go into manager level.
But if you say 5 years, then definitely
I would look myself as a solution
architect which can architect
uh every solution and
object
and I should be fully knowledgeable. So,
it should go like if it Hussein has said
this should be done, then it should be
done. So, I have to reach there and to
reach there I have to rigorously be
first
very much skilled a DevOps engineer in
the era of AI. As you said that you have
to adapt to AI to reach there. Uh so,
after doing that after 5 years, I will
be at a solution architect level where
still I want to stay connected with the
technology. Not just manage things and
and get things done, but I want to
create architectures and I want to work
as a like a hardcore engineer.
Okay. Okay. So, even with solution
architect, so sometimes people kind of
misinterpret the role of an architect.
Okay. So, I worked as an architect for 6
years. And for all 6 years I was doing
hands-on work. Yeah. So, there is a thin
line between an engineer and architect.
So, engineer is something who who
actually
do the hands-on work. An architect is
someone who who can
do the solutioning, who can create
beautiful diagrams and create the entire
ecosystem, but he also needs to
um
be hands-on just in case if required,
right? Correct.
>> So,
that is that is where
it it needs to go.
Okay.
Yeah, apart from that one last question.
So,
um
I see a lot of tussle between DevOps
engineers and developers, right?
So, how will you ensure that the
friction between
you as a DevOps engineer and the
developer
is reduced and and the the the work is
not compromised?
>> [snorts]
>> Correct. Yeah. So, our position is also
like that. It's DevOps. That is
developers and
system that that consists of this
developers and operations. So,
definitely that is a lot of tussle that
this work should be done by developers.
No, no, this work should be done by
DevOps. So, we usually face that issue,
but
this is something where we both have to
be knowledgeable in on each other's
task. Let's say if anyone wants to
deploy anything on Kubernetes, then I
have also have to know how the APIs work
inside the application and the
developers also should have some
knowledge on how Kubernetes work. So,
this is again
from both ends we have to be
knowledgeable.
Of course, in the next industry,
if you're not that skilled enough, it is
very much hard for you to survive.
So, and also here is where the tech lead
comes into picture, your manager comes
into picture, and he lays down the task
and he makes sure that we are working as
one team and not different handover
task. We have to make sure
while developing anything, I also have
to be there and while developing CICD
pipelines and deployments, the developer
also should be somewhat knowledgeable on
how things are done.
Right. Right. Yeah. Yeah, that was a
good answer, Hussein. So, thanks a lot
for taking this interview and taking out
time for this mock interview.
I think a lot of people will benefit out
of this conversation.
Anything you would like to ask me or
uh anything that comes to your mind or
maybe we can wrap up.
Uh yeah, first of all, thank you so much
for having this and taking your time out
as well. I even hope that people get
most out of the interviews that we are
doing. Uh one question I would like to
ask you that you have been 14 years of
experience. So, what is your next goal?
Like after 5 years or 10 years, how do
you see yourself and how do you see as a
DevOps industry? How it will grow in
next 5 years in next 10 years? What
advice would you give for to freshers
who wants to build a career in DevOps?
Yeah. Yeah. So, I'll answer this
question in general, right? Not not
specific to DevOps, right? When I
started working, I started like in the
introduction I mentioned that for the
initial 6 to 7 years I was into software
development. When I
when I was into like 4 to 5 years, I I
was like fascinated like with
designations. Like used to feel like
managers, directors.
And I thought that I'll also become a
manager or a director one day. But right
now, I'm leading a team of 30 technical
people, right? But I I'm still doing 3
to 4 hours of hands-on work. Yeah. Uh I
will consider myself successful
over the next 5 to 7 years if I'm able
to maintain that 5 to 4 to 5 hours of
hands-on job. Okay, hands-on work. Yeah.
So,
I consider people should not worry too
much about the designation. With the
advent of AI,
I think every single person needs to
stay hands-on or they will get absolute,
okay? So,
that is going to happen for sure.
You will see a smaller number of teams,
right? So, initially
with uh big companies used to see
thousands and thousands of engineers,
but it is slowly changing, okay? So,
there are startups with like 5 to 10
engineers and they're doing
multi-million dollars of business.
So, that is going to happen
over the next 5 years, I believe.
Uh a person should have at least basic
information or basic knowledge of all
the aspects.
Um and with the help of AI, they can
learn other stuff as well, right? So,
um if you ask me, full stack uh is is
the need of the hour. So, a person needs
to understand front end, back end,
databases, and cloud and DevOps. So, uh
even it is okay if they are not expert
in a particular area, but they need to
understand all the stuff. And with white
coding tools and other new tools that
coming up in the market, they can write
software. They can create enterprise
grade solutions. It is not there yet,
but maybe in the couple of years it can
reach that state. Having said that,
it is going to give you
problems. It is going to fail in
production. It is going It
maybe it will not work. But you should
be having the capability to make changes
to that AI written code. Okay, that is
what I said.
There are a lot of people who do a lot
of white coding. So, at the MVP stage,
they they are like very successful, but
when it
hits production, they start to face
scaling issues. They start to face
security issues.
That is where the main challenge or your
experience comes into picture, okay? So,
the people with no programming
experience or no DevOps experience or no
software engineering experience will
feel over there.
And
we need to make sure that at least we
should be able to make changes or update
the code that AI has written, okay? So
to sum it up, I would say that if I am I
stay hands-on over the next 5 years
regardless of where I am or what kind of
a designation I am in.
But I I still want to keep hands-on.
That is what I can say.
Hope I I was able to answer your
question. Yes, yes, definitely.
Yeah.
All right,
Hussein I It was a good time talking to
you.
Maybe we'll catch up later. Thank you.
>> Sure, yes. Thank you so much.